general electric ce géant américain de
l'énergie et du transport qui emploie
3700 salariés sur le site de belfort
connu surtout pour ses turbines à gaz et
à vapeur alimentant centrale nucléaire
électrique en 2014 geely rachète la
branche énergie d'alstom et parle d'un
millier d'emplois créés d'ici 2019
la promesse ne sera pas tenu aujourd'hui
il est plutôt question d'un plan de
départs volontaires annoncé il ya
quelques jours entre 150 et 200 postes à
belfort colères et inquiétudes chez les
syndicats
pendant ces trois dernières années j
organise et l'insatisfaction travail
d'insatisfaction dans les conditions
d'emploi dans les conditions de travail
l'organisation du travail elle-même et
est donc aujourd'hui on voit que geely
va se retranchait derrière ce
volontariat des salariés alors que ceux
cédés par son sont organisés depuis
plusieurs années l'intérêt du groupe
general electric est de dégager des
dividendes dégager du cash
ce n'est pas l'intérêt de général
éthique à belfort ou en tout cas de
l'industrie à belfort à belfort on
souhaite maintenir l'industrie
pour l'instant ce n'est qu'une partie de
la branche énergie du groupe qui est
concernée soit 1300 personnes environ à
belfort une annonce qui laisse perplexe
certains élus ce qu'on aimerait surtout
c'est que generali tous disent où ils
veulent aller parce qu'on peut qu'on
peut entendre que les marchés sont
fluctuants qui à des baises mais quand
il ya des syndicats il ya plein de gens
qui propose de nouvelles options avec
l'aéronautique etc et on sent pas
general electric nous dire ok à belfort
y ait des compétences utilisons-les pour
faire autre chose c'est ça qui est
plutôt inquiétant c'est pas seulement le
fait de la baisse de commandes c'est de
dire attention gardez quelque chose et
dans les départs volontaires le risque
qu'on le connaît aussi ses qui est des
personnes compétentes qui s'en aille et
qu'on appauvrisse le site et après quand
tu auras plus personne de compétent va
nous dire voyez vous n'êtes plus
capables de produire on va ailleurs
en trois ans l'action de ji a chuté
passant de 30 à 10 dollars l'entreprise
qui refuse les interviews nous a affirmé
procéder à une revue de ses activités
et pour garantir leur succès à long
terme